you're not supposed to be in my
introduction I'm sorry I get that the
van anyway the crowbars right here yeah
yeah you like my new microphone yeah all
right anyway now I can finally go here I
hope it sounds good everything all right
Pete pie-o-my yeah yeah
hey I'm 110,000 I am freakin rich Boris
is gonna be all like girl you pimp girl
I'm boy what are you talking about girl
I can't just open this come on yeah yeah
I still have the crowbar that's awesome
all right hello hello what's going on
here I don't like that door all right
it's going here
hello hey refill of oil no need the
Lancers Oh
so Princeton you learn to put it well
first time I'm not even out of I got
sneezing coming Hey - what are you doing
all right I think I need to pull this
lever does that think I can see me it's
cool huh forgive me please
both the [ __ ] are you crying for oh all
right you fake one I think the Lord the
sound of the engine started the monster
I gotta sneeze why do I have to sneeze
all right any protection pearl it down
okay we got this Dan
I have to spinner of this you spin the
room spinning I'm spinning I'm spinning
alright yeah yeah how much does this go
this is ridiculous
spin faster they're coming
[Applause]
I like this good all right
I made it all right we're good we're
good we're good oh so close so Klaus
freaking spot him oh I came I came close
to dying I did not expect that no sir
hey we need to spin the wheel why didn't
you tell me I thought they were gonna
come from there all like sweet baby
Jesus sweet baby Jesus he's not happy
he's crying tears tears of sadness okay
hold the ladder pity oh I'm not yeah
yeah what do you want from me stop not
again thank you God dad why would you
proof at me like that I'm not a [ __ ]
okay
spin the wheel I am gonna spin the whale
table tally what the [ __ ] today spend a
little pit stop golly we watched it out
a spinning
I'm looking at you
come on can it be faster Jesus guys I'm
spinning like a [ __ ] come on is
that it
yes go go don't you dare teleport in my
face don't you dad tell upon my face
slide Indiana Jones slide [ __ ] yeah
yeah all right let me see him come here
come on bring it bring it
ha stupid shot of a penis I Spit on your
toes oh oh I sped on that that's true
yet
I am up to good start yeah let's dance
battle I feeling movie tonight
yay you're looking fine tonight better
bad nuts kidding
don't you guys think anybody on that
second
hey what oh that all right let's going
on how to buy things you can buck I can
buy with why thousands you can buy
things by simply pulling a lever of the
are be desired and you need to Ricardo
Mountain coins can't be found everywhere
I already knew that
falling land Nana them and Tina Marxist
whoo I got my old Adnan and I'm I got
alright boys haven't seen many guys in
my shop hear that location I came here a
long time I came from the bill good
location my castle but I didn't say it
would be in the freakin basement
I'm sorry you know I don't trust him
your name's not boys I can't throw
barrels at him it's not fat hey father I
love spinny like you all right no I
can't think just feel it just blending
in the background by all the light not
gnome you mean and I will meet you on
the other side all right all right
Stefano whatever you say buddy what is
this song from this is Donkey Kong I
don't remember a good deal yeah yeah
what a good deal thank you for that Wow
you really need those things don't you
some kind of pervert that when I'm
pulling a lever anything but did not
know that you could find that much money
around here all right he's definitely a
slime
I mean oil yes I did not know that you
could find water on medieval you knew
that you could find irony is 10 my
damaged a good deal what a good deal
what's a good deal you can try again
oh no no no nobody's my man my friend I
will see you later okay
it's the final no I'll see you too i
whatever pale it's toppings to it what
are you talking about Stefano all right
I see you both later
it was very nice making a business with
you bad all right
how thoughtful all right let's go did
you come back soon you're my only
strength oh we are best via broads you
12
all right check note to self don't don't
do accents what the hell I do accents hi
oh no the serious begins right okay wait
um I'm gonna be right back and it's
gonna all right everything was working
uh yeah and your microphone you gotta
make sure you know oh snap ah don't you
dad tell them I don't come here I don't
[ __ ] it come here please they're [ __ ]
alright I hate that [ __ ] penis game
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] yes
I mean [ __ ] about sand a [ __ ] Persian
[Music]
he's blind I forgot
he's [ __ ] blind oh hey I shot thing
my penis okay
how the [ __ ] am I gonna do that maybe if
I throw a barrel he don't get distracted
[ __ ] my son is so low if I know her she
what about sandy potions alright let's
just do this huh [ __ ] my [ __ ] about
oh oh thank penis
oh thank penis oh oh oh my god no I
don't think my penis I think my behind I
think I have overdone it right now okay
breakdowns over here breakdowns over
here Daniel thank you alright this No I
need a key somewhere around here can I
please go in here without the [ __ ]
door [ __ ] my life up huh
you're not so tough now are you door huh
oh sorry
alright let's keep going dude [ __ ] stop
please stop
everyone just [ __ ] take a chill pill
alright it's not cool ah teleporting me
thud thuds I know town fathers hey- want
a naked guy [ __ ] you and [ __ ] all of you
alright I need a key there
why did we go whoa look at this
look at his hand he's like come with me
PD this way I have a candy over here oh
[ __ ]
I'm sorry baby I just came to deliver a
message
I came to block the salsa The Lying
Tirzah oh no oh no this is gas tank ah
ah ah yeah ah yeah God [ __ ] you
nope back to the ooh oh ah oh come on I
swear to God if there's another [ __ ]
Kufa eilen come here please don't come
here please don't come here please don't
come here please don't come here please
don't come and play don't come here
please don't commit please don't come
here please don't come here please
did you see that guy's ass did you know
you're doing cuz you're [ __ ] dead are
you alright yeah I think it's good
he better not be returning I'm sick of
these [ __ ] proof first [ __ ] my
life up it's better to be the real
[ __ ] deal alright he gone he proved
he proved that he snooped what the hell
is this [ __ ] isn't know it's where
unexpected map design I must say how did
you ladder doesn't look like a ladder
but I climb it anyway I mean if it is a
ladder
it is a ladder and that's Peter pie if
it is a ladder it's a ladder genius
genius
hey pal tots I love $50 I am rich I will
go to the Boris and we will all smile
all of his drugs all of it yes Oh
[ __ ] stop where is it possible you
come from that zombie make no sense
ah come on this [ __ ] custard story
this [ __ ] penis
it's [ __ ] penis all right I have a
sledgehammer [ __ ] like these ladder
shots 360 pages yeah yeah
MLG [ __ ] yeah yeah ah nothing no I
don't see anything bad can happen when
there's alright I have your pal service
are you [ __ ] kidding me
alright I'm hiding in here
he's coming please don't find me sick of
this [ __ ] I'm sick of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god I was [ __ ] mattress
mattress like Mia
I don't want to play anymore today good
end of here I'm gonna go watch some
kitty cats that's it
[Music]